i i'm just a person that was very lucky
i did something that i liked
since i was a kid which was writing code
getting into computers at the time it
was
it wasn't a popular thing
[Music]
oren du bronski thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders how are
you
very good thank you for having me i am
blushing i'm a huge huge fan
and i have to say i'm a huge fan on
several fronts first of all your homos
helped me get through many final exams
at stanford and not just me
but about all of my dorm that it's it's
the it's stanford's favorite restaurant
have no doubt
and second thing is the direct flight
between
san francisco and tel aviv i believe you
had quite a quite an important hand in
making that happen
so my father myself and everybody else i
really thank you for that
but more importantly than that or and
you have an incredible streamline of
of of entrepreneurship endeavors that
you've had most recently
an incredible unclear giving that i
can't wait to hear about and but also a
pretty prominent now tv persona through
the sharks in israel
so wow organ
why how do you do so many things
um i don't know i guess i guess i can't
help it that's the right answer
i love that answer but um tell me how
you started
you you went to mom and from there
how how does this happen so so so i
consider myself very lucky
that that's the that's the bottom line i
i'm just a person that was very lucky i
did something that i liked
since i was a kid which was writing code
getting into computers at the time it
was
it wasn't a popular thing my parents
used to shout at me you know why did you
go out and play
and i said i just love it and i used to
play a lot
with my computer and then it was very
natural for me to go to my mom
and when i was uh uh leaving the army it
was 96
and i really had this vision of what the
internet can happen and back then in
israel in 96
very few people thought you know
about the upcoming revolution so i
started my first startup in 97
just because i felt that again this was
like i had to be to do something about
it and i
i created my first you know startup it
was the first craigslist i didn't even
know about craigslist but i started a
craigslist in israel
uh a bulletin board and uh i mean
the year wasn't the the market wasn't
ready so i had to close that a year
later it was a big heartache and thank
god i had a girlfriend at the time who
told me you must work on the second one
i told her you know it doesn't work this
internet
and she said no no you must do it and so
i started my second one and then i
basically
uh uh hit the jackpot i i i came up with
a concept of
a toolbar and i wrote a patent over a
toolbar and that became you know history
literally everywhere that that is hot
bar correct right that was hot bar
um we had a an estimate that we had like
one in every four computers in the world
had our toolbar installed at the time
that is
that is just unbelievable talk to me a
little bit about that
that resilience of being a young
entrepreneur your your first startup
fails
with the inspiration and motivation from
your girlfriend you move on to the
second startup and it skyrockets to the
point where
right where you're literally in in a
quarter of the computers in the world
what was that transition like how do you
fathom that transition
well you know even then uh the
the mindset it was so everything was so
every day every day
there were new things people didn't
really know they would know today it's
funny today when you start stuff
there's so much material to read about
and to learn you know even when you went
to stanford
at the time there was nothing anyone who
did anything in the internet space it
was all discovery it was a totally like
uh
wild west think about it this way you
know we needed to invent
you know from the methodologies and you
know
what are you going to do how you're
going to there were no tools and to
build everything yourself
obviously there was no cloud uh so we we
needed really to figure out what we were
doing
and uh you know it it also the the
markets were difficult so then 2000 came
and everything tanked
and we needed to you know stay afloat in
a very difficult year
unbelievable you know i have to say
different times i have to say that
you know i spent five years in 8200
which was a phenomenal experience i'm
sure
very similar to to the experience at mom
and then
going to california and seeing what's
happening there literally
every corner at stanford there's a class
teaching you how to start a startup
every kid that walks on campus is
thinking what am i gonna do
in 97 98 that wasn't the case you didn't
have
a class on every corner helping you
which is amazing
no that was not there was nothing we you
know we
uh i needed to explain that what i'm
doing is i'm a computer's company
in a special field called the internet
it was kind of a subset
of being in computers wow that that is
just unbelievable
i want to fast forward the journey a
little bit and i want to make sure that
we that we can
very soon get clear giving them your
most recent endeavor
but you have two two stints along the
way that are very
irregular for the average you know
silicon valley entrepreneur the first
one is something that we can all thank
you for
allowing us to travel back and forth tel
aviv and san francisco
that is a startup by itself it sounds
like because that was that was quite a
journey tell me a little bit about that
well well that was totally an irrational
thing to do right so
i was living in the valley i moved to
the valley in 2008 so i
at first i moved to new york in 2000 i
lived there eight years
i already sold my startup hot bar
i exited i made some money and i had
another one that one also went well
and then i moved to the valley and then
living in the valley
having to take this daunting flight to
tel aviv
once or twice a year when you need to
start somewhere and collect your luggage
and move it to a different terminal and
all kind of crazy
you know i just said this cannot be the
case so i
i you know i i contacted united and they
said to me you know when
there's just not enough demand and i
said well
this is not possible there's so many
startups here
so many israelis but not just israel
here there's so many
american startups that are you know i
have a location in israel
that need to fly people from google to
face i mean anyone i knew
had a big big center in tel aviv and so
i decided to do a petition
and you know and 10 about 10 000 people
signed a petition committing to flight
of 36 thousand flights
countless tickets and with that i
basically came back to all the airlines
and i said guys there is a demand
and uh there was a phase there you know
that they just
that united just got tired of me
and you know it's funny because after
they
launched that direct client two months
after that they had this national
convention they have an annual
convention where all the managers meet
in united
and the guy who is in charge on route
planning is uh
going to the stage and he says the
following he says i don't know
how these israelis need more than all
our algorithms
but this is the number one flight in our
network and we couldn't see it
and that that that is really unique how
can you how do you explain that
is it that when they fly under the road
you know i look i think that they looked
at tel aviv and san francisco as two
random
locations like you know boston and rome
okay
interesting i don't know these are two
tech hubs right
that the the the companies who worked
in these places will definitely use your
business class
right they will if you have an option to
fly direct
they will not fly indirect because of
price
yes and uh you know maybe it's my fault
that the prices went so high
but united said you know okay so let's
have a bigger business class let's you
know
charge a lot of money and guess what
people just were willing to pay any
price to have a direct flight instead of
wasting a day i mean it's it's it's a
very simple market
right you're on one hand when you're
when you have the regular flight you're
applying to the larger market most of it
is
it is business and leisure but here not
many people take a vacation to san
francisco right that's not that's not
the best
so so i think that's just but but that
was minor compared to
the the innovative nature of or orange
hummus
that i that i met you know i have to say
owen i'm in tel aviv
i eat hummus here every day and somehow
i find myself missing your restaurant
and not just no way i don't know that is
you are you you are too sweet you are
dude
you introduced you introduced to the
jaffa right they also met the off menu
jaffa dish that one of the waiters told
me about
and since then uh so so tell me a little
bit about why why start at home
so again you know as an entrepreneur you
just can't help it
but you always see what needs to be done
you always say
what is missing what is what can be done
better what is not right
you know um here i have to admit
that not only that i saw how much it was
missing i myself missed thomas
yes i used to go to eat hummus before i
bought a plane to go to san francisco
and when i come back i use the first
thing to do is go to ethan
yes and i said you know let's have a
place basically
for the israelis i didn't think about it
too much i just wanted a place for
us and my wife thought at the time that
i was a little bit crazy
and i told her you know nancy you're all
right she's living like a midlife crisis
but we'll have a place and and she has
experience i was very lucky to have her
because she has a
restaurant experience and so she she
helped me open it in the beginning
because i didn't know what i was doing
and the one thing that i insisted on is
that we will keep it like the best
the best quality possible we were not
aiming
into profitability we said we are going
to and let me give you an example so
from day one we would import the grains
themselves from
israel in a boat think about that
gray needs to go halfway around the
world to be on your plate
and the tahini we bought the whole pita
machine because there were no decent
peters in
the radius so it was really um how would
i say it it was not a financial project
it was a
project that comes from the soul and you
know some people are saying that this is
the recipe for success i don't know if
that's true but it really came from a
place
to do the best the best food i can do
uh my only role was i mean other than
financing it my only role was to make
sure that the taste is the way i
remember it
to be as authentic because some people
along the way suggested that maybe we
should
uh adjust it to the american palate and
i said no way we are going to do it
exactly the way it is in israel and i
think that's that's where the charm is
that suddenly there was such different
days such
different experience i mean when we
opened we had americans who came in and
the fact that you use your hand
to whip the pita on the big walls
you have that yeah a honest eating guide
right
we explain how to do it because people
didn't know how to do it
and you know somebody told me you know
this is the best place for a date
you just come and you share and you have
i mean it was it's
it's unique so when you say that you
miss it when you're in israel you know
in israel there's a hummus in every
corner and
people are like die-hard fans of one
hummus and they don't never step in
another hummus
california was a desert i mean if there
were anywhere
near a decent hummus i wouldn't have
opened the only reason i opened is that
i couldn't find
anything decent and oran of course i
have to mention that the missing
ingredient from everything that you
mentioned which exists
there is when you walk down university
avenue or castro
you hear aziz coming from one of
the restaurants
and that that just forms the heart of
every israeli that walks there
but oran we have to totally be my wife
that's totally my wife yes yes
that's genius we have to fast forward
because we only have 20 minutes we have
to still talk about clear giving
and we we completely skipped over the
fact that you're a huge tv celebrity in
israel now
known as a startup guru investing as
part of the shark tank show but we'll
we'll leave that for another discussion
you
after all of that incredible uh success
in endeavors
which i have to say that the most
inspirational part for me is not the
toolbar and it's not the start of a 97
it's a it's about this lifelong
mentality of being an entrepreneur
and it's about your your motivation to
go and fix whatever you see happening
around you
and i think that that is just so
incredible and that's a mentality that i
wish for myself i wish for all my
friends
and for everybody that's surrounding me
and so i really want to thank you for
that
i talked to me a little bit about clear
giving what happened that you said
now i want to make a social impact yeah
so you know clear giving is
is actually a continuation of a project
that i did for many years before that so
when i had some money to give um
and i i really started to struggle where
i'm getting it i felt that just giving
it to the first
random non-profit is just not the right
thing you need to treat it with respect
as if
this is you know you are serious about
uh getting it to the right places and
none of the non-profits none of the
organizations that i worked with
offered the level of transparency that i
would
use to usually give a big sum of money
but you don't really know what happened
you don't know right you don't know
where it goes you have no control of
where you're going
so for many years i used to employ uh
an individual who used to find me
families
in me that i could support them directly
so after doing that for more than 10
years
i basically decided you know what how
about taking it to the next level how
about
productizing it and basically doing
again what i
i wished would be when i started giving
which is basically uh someone who could
build for you uh a portfolio of families
right and and and that's that's
basically how i started clear giving i
basically said
we will make a website where we first of
all we screen
families uh that need support in israel
we get them all from the vaha which is
the social services
in israel the governmental social
services we screen them
they need to pass certain criteria
before we
upload a certain profile of them on the
website obviously it's anonymous you
cannot know who they are
but you get to know the story so you as
a donor you can go into the website and
choose families you want to support
amazing initially we initially called it
like adopt a family
some people felt it's like too much so
we said you know let's call it clear
giving
another big feature other than knowing
who you are giving the money is that we
said a hundred percent of the donation
goes to the family
so we separate the operational cost we
have dedicated donors for operational
cost at this point
it's me but in the future it can be
other people as well
but the vast majority of donors if they
give a dollar then a dollar goes to a
a needy family so that is it
that gives you a feeling that you are
not you know we are not
there's no conflict of interest
this is the i like to say it's the
biggest bang for the bot you give
ten thousand dollars ten thousand
dollars go to families like that there's
no
right nothing being taken out i have to
ask because first of all regarding that
last point it's fascinating because
truth because when they do take a cut or
a margin from the donation then you then
obviously the more they market the more
they make and then there's a conflict of
interest
but i have to ask about the distinction
a lot of the non-profits that i'm aware
of and a lot of the organizations
you give them the money and they promise
that they'll disseminate it to those
that are in need
but you don't have that story you're
missing that individuality aspect
and when you're mentioning that you're
telling the story of a family even
though it's anonymized
i feel like i'm giving to that family so
tell me about that
you you you picked it so i want to make
that i want to give the benefit
to you as a donor that you know
who you helped it's like if it wasn't
for you
they did not have food on the table
right i mean this is
literally you chose them you pick them
and your money is going to them and you
get reports to the last
cent you know where where it went
another important thing that we said is
that we believe
that helping people in need is something
that you know
um people who need food people who need
clothing people who need
basic basic things i want to help them i
i you know there are many many
non-profits today they help
on a on a higher magnitude you know we
will build a big
uh you know whatever nasa is uh a big
school we will become a community center
yeah we will change poverty you know
what
i think it's important but i think it's
also important
to help the poor person
who cannot feed his kids or who cannot
buy his
daughter you know uh ballet
ballet hobby because he doesn't have
money and
just think about the drama that these
people are living in if you can help
them
get something you know so so basic that
we all are
taking for granted um i think that's a
big mitzvah i think
i think people need to think about it
when they do philanthropy they need to
say you know
i have big big goals and i have you know
immediate help that i can offer i like
to say it's like
it's like you're planning a financial
portfolio right you sometimes
invest in high risk you go to startups
and you go to
maybe equity but you also have bonds and
with low risk
products and the same thing here you
need to think long term
but you also need to give fish to your
the the poor person who's standing at
your door
and and is asking you cannot tell him oh
no i'm going to send the kid to the
university you know that's nice
i'm going to give a tuition to a kid
write a scholarship yeah that's nice but
what about the young people who need the
the help right now and so i i like to
think that this is the solution
what we started doing and i think it's
it's valuable to say is that
we started as really offering this
service to
anyone with a credit card so people
could you know give ten dollars or
five dollars whatever they want they can
give and it's a monthly thing that they
support the family
by the way whenever we get to 200 a
month
that's that's what we want to raise per
family then that family goes off the
site
and you know now we will help another
family wow
that's the quota but my point is that we
recently started doing you know
basically a service to bigger donors so
people who want to give me ten thousand
dollars right or
or twenty thousand dollars and what we
said is that we would build a portfolio
for them think about it as a manager
yes yes i was just about to ask about
that right
so so it's 200 a month right times 12
it's 24.
for 2400 a year
you can basically take a family in need
families with very difficult stories and
you know basically move
them into a totally different place you
know it might not change them
it's not they're not poor anymore but
you know you take
so much drama bad drama out of their
life
you give them you know support you give
them the basics
now whatever extra money they have to
use you know on buying something they
buy a new
you know shoes for the kids right or
stuff like that but then even
think about it if you for ten thousand
four four almost eleven thousand like
ten thousand eight hundred
you help five families
a year right i i don't think other
non-profits you know can
offer something like that because
usually again when you think long term
then you need to invest more when it
takes longer and things are more
costly but here for 10 for eleven
thousand dollars
you basically can help five families and
and and this is what we are aiming now
we are aiming now for
people who basically come to me and say
look i'm giving you
um a budget think about like a bank
account i'm giving you a budget
and you will build me a portfolio
families these families will stay with
them
we are not going to switch them they
will be your
families we will update you what's going
on with them
from time to time they might write you a
letter you know but basically you will
know that you support these families
i think that's remarkable when you
mentioned about the families not being
poor anymore but
at least they'll give them comfort i i'm
a huge fan of of the pyramid of maslow i
remember when i
when i learned about it first in middle
school
i understood it so well i was going
through a heartache with a girlfriend
and i couldn't function because
i didn't have my that that baseline
filled
and i can only imagine how difficult it
is for a family and i'm very privileged
to come from a valley where i never had
to worry about food on the table
but by giving them the food by giving
them
some comfort you're allowing them to
think more critically about how they can
then improve on the other things
and it's like it's like a rolling ball
it's a spiral totally
i i love it although i think think about
the shame
of the parents that need to look in the
kids eyes when they cannot afford buying
them
shoes i you know when i think about it
i'm starting to wall
i'm tearing up right now yeah i have
kids i if
we if i would have a situation that i
could not afford buying them something
that is
pretty much basic that other kids have
you know this is
this is a terrible situation so the two
hundred dollars a month
uh is as small as it sounds makes a huge
difference for these families
unfortunately there are so many families
here in israel now especially you know
we didn't speak about that but
now with the corona you know i i
returned to israel for a year i took a
gap year now in august
for a year after 20 years in the states
and you know
i was shocked the corona literally took
families who were already in a good
place and put them in a bad place those
that were in a bad place it put them in
a place that you cannot imagine so
the level of poverty you usually you
don't see it because when you
you know stay in tel aviv tel aviv is
like another country it's like the
silicon valley and
the state of tel aviv yeah right right
when you move out of tel aviv when you
go to houlon and lord and
you know all these places you cannot
believe what stories we found
and uh again i i would say you know if
if now is a time if there was ever a
time to give
to help people directly it's now now
it's not a time to say you know what i'm
going to save for your tuition i'm going
to change the education system
now now is the time to just give all
then
thank you for all the amazing work that
you're doing you're touching literally
so many lives before this after this
doing this thank you very very much
before we leave i have to ask you the
most important question which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself oh my goodness um
[Music]
well i'm definitely an entrepreneur yeah
but i would like to say
i would like to say that if i'm a world
benefactor
that's that's my goal in life and world
benefits
yeah i want to make this world better on
many levels
um i love that's how i see myself
entrepreneur world benefactor i love it
thank you very very much okay my name is
really granting me
of course thank you for having me